what's going on guys today we're going
to be going through the spoilers from my
academia chapter 322 which picks up
where we left off last week with uh
either tearfully embracing deku's hand
and also monetary confessing his
romantic feelings okay that part with
moneta wasn't actually meant to be
romantic but it did start a whole 100
thousand tweet discussion on twitter
with people just debating what it could
mean but in my humble opinion i don't
think meredith swings that way i mean at
least not yet anyway anyway the spoilers
for today do look pretty good but as
usual for a thursday we have a full
chapter summary but the panels and stuff
aren't fully released there are a couple
of them here and there but for the most
part it is just the summary before we
get into it don't forget to hit that sub
button if you want to see more spoiler
videos like this every thursday uh
because admittedly i haven't done them
for a while and that was because it was
taking a long time to edit them and you
know just getting really long but when
i'm on camera it is a lot easier so if
you want to see more let me know in the
comments down below okay so the title of
this chapter is great explosion god
dynamite which is obviously baccago's
full hero name and uh while this isn't a
backup centric chapter it definitely has
one very important moment for the
character that's been building for a
really long time so the chapter starts
with deku thinking that he has to break
free from edith's hand but he has no
power left at that moment achaka
released her quirk so decker and ida
were both free-falling from the sky and
either worried they couldn't land safely
but hiroshima was there to catch them
at that moment kiroshima told deku that
back in the day when they were still
middle schoolers he heard that there's a
guy who ran off to save his friend and
this is referring to the sludgement
incident when deku ran to save back ago
even though he was quercus at the time
and could you know he could have died um
and as we know from kirishima's
flashback he heard about this story he
asked deku if he was the guy that tried
to save bakugou and kiroshima says that
the deku of that time is their answer
this is implying that he doesn't want
any more dark deku he wants the og deku
the one who's you know willing to just
jump in and save his friends and work
with his friends um as opposed to the
one that runs away from his friends and
doesn't want to be with them either
asked hiroshima how his timing was so
nice and kirishima says that it was
endeavour's order which is a reference
to the last chapter when endeavour
basically just said you know go in get
deku and he told hawks not to intervene
the rest of the class then approached
them and mina told deku to come back to
ua but deku says he doesn't want to
because he's scared and he doesn't want
to cause trouble for other people he
continues by saying that he can't go
back to how things used to be and this
is when bakugou intervenes and he asks
deku if he remembers what he said after
he got impaled by shigaraki deku says he
doesn't remember and bakugou reminds him
that he says don't try to win this on
your own so what this is referring to is
back in the war arc when midoriya was uh
you know he was pretty much trying to
defeat afo by himself and then there was
a point where baku his body just moves
without thinking and he intervenes gets
in deku's way and gets impaled and the
first thing he says after that was you
know don't try to win this on your own
because at that point that was literally
what deku were trying to do now all
these weeks later midori is doing the
exact same thing again and he's you know
trying to defeat afo by himself trying
to find him so
baku is kind of saying you know don't
follow that same path bakugou then goes
on to say that at the moment he got
impaled he realized to himself that
there was something he had to tell deku
in his mind midori was always someone
that he looked down on because deku was
always quirkless but although deku
should be far behind him bakugo felt
that somehow he was far ahead of him he
didn't like that feeling he didn't want
to admit it and so instead of you know
acknowledging what was going on inside
him he basically pushed deku away and
began bullying him this is bakugo
basically confessing that ever since
they were kids even when midori was
quirkless he somehow felt in his mind
midori was ahead of him and that's why
he bullied him to try and keep him down
so yeah it's a
a lot of us kind of suspected that but
it is interesting to see that this is
finally 100 confirmed after they entered
you away nothing went according to how
we planned and every day was filled with
realizing deku's strengths and
understanding his own weaknesses bakugou
said that although he said all of this
he knows that it won't do any justice
and make up for all the pain that he's
caused azuku over the years but still
these are his real feelings he then says
to izuku sorry for everything until now
and
this is the moment that we've been
waiting for for a super long time um i
felt that it's been building up for this
for a while i think the very first
moment was possibly you know deku vs cat
jan 2. that was probably like the
beginning when they began to become a
bit more civil towards each other and
then obviously during the war arc when
bakugou and all might had that flashback
conversation that was a real big hint as
to the way it was going and now here
this is the combination of that we see
bakugou literally just straight up
apologizing saying sorry for everything
i was jealous of you i you know you were
quirkless i still felt intimidated so i
tried to keep you down and yeah that's
it i mean
pretty big moment for the series bakugou
continued by saying that the path declan
almighty took wasn't wrong but right now
deku is unsteady and there are certain
things that even ideals can't surpass
for the things that deku can't do by
himself he wants midoriya to let class
when they handle it and this includes
saving the civilians saving their
refugees at ua and also saving deku
himself this is bakugo truly embracing
the save to win mindset which is
something that he briefly did during the
uh the joint training arc as well but
historically you know this has usually
been more of deku and almost personality
but you can see here bakugou is
embracing it he's acknowledging that he
has to save these people including deku
the refugees and the civilians so yeah i
mean this is this chapter is is super
important for bakuga's development it is
just acknowledging how much he has grown
this is the combination of everything
that's happened so far after this there
was then some narration and deku was
saying that all of his classmates were
already leagues ahead of him so what i
think he's referring to is when he first
started at ua because at that point deku
had no control over his power the other
guys were so far ahead they've been
they've been trading with their quotes
their whole lives so at that point they
were leagues ahead of him and he then
starts regretting what he said to them
in the last chapter about how now they
can't keep up midoriya then says he's
sorry and apologizes and suddenly his
body gives in but bakago catches him
just before he hits the ground now this
is a little bit unsurprising because if
you think about it just before class
when i arrived deku was already
stumbling along the ground he was you
know he'd been going hard for about a
week straight you know without any sleep
so it's not that surprising that he
would collapse after this whole uh
encounter with class 1a and yeah bakugo
catches him which is a pretty cool
moment although i haven't seen a panel
for this yet so it would be interesting
to see what that looks like the summary
says that class 1a looks tired and
relieved and momo goes on to say that
they resolve the first problem but now
the next one may be even harder the
chapter then has a little bit of a flash
forward to when they reach away and at
this point midori is slowly starting to
open his eyes now the students are all
hurrying so they can warn number 13 of
what's about to happen and for the first
time ever we can see that she's not
wearing a helmet so you know
i remember in the first season it kind
of looked like she was made of nothing
uh but no for the first time we see what
she looks like and
nothing really particularly uh unique
about her i mean she looks like a normal
woman has a little bit of a little bit
of curly hair but yeah i mean nothing
much to say about her really number 13
tells them that all of the peaceful
civilians have been located under an
evacuation area and the ones that are
outside are mostly groups of anti-hero
protesters or extremists that have gone
wild alongside the jailbreakers what
this means is that most civilians who
are just normal people who don't want to
fight they are in the evacuation areas
and everyone who's outside is either i
mean essentially a villain or they're
just people who are upset with the
heroes 13 goes on to say that more and
more protesters are giving up and they
are going to the evacuation zones so
that is a good thing i suppose because
if you remember many many chapters ago
when uh was that guy's name again i
think his name is yeah yoshindo so he
was trying to get these guys to go to
the evacuation zones and a lot of people
were just like like we don't want to
leave like we don't trust you heroes
we're going to say we're going to defend
ourselves but as time goes on less and
less i think people are starting to
realize that is not a smart thing you
know you can't beat villains by yourself
so yeah overall the situation in japan
is getting better and the extremists aka
the villains are getting a lot more easy
to catch
13 says that deku's solo journey
defeating the villains has really helped
the heroes and police and that much is
undeniable because i think the heroes
would have really struggled to beat some
of the villains that deku was defeated
the one that's in my mind is muscular
because you know besides endeavor and
besides best genius i feel like most
heroes would have really really
struggled against him so deku has
definitely been helping out that much
you can't deny it you just can't deny it
the one thing he did wrong was looking
so scary and intimidating because i
think a lot of people just assume he's a
villain now
but no i mean overall deku did do the
right thing
but now it's time to come back to school
and yeah we'll just see what happens
from there surrounding the school the ua
barrier is now active and according to
the leaks it looks like a giant iron
fortress sarah comments that this is
just a taste of what it can actually do
and he says that when the system is
activated it even connects to shiketsu
high that being said deku is still
worried about going back to ua because
by doing so he kind of puts the school
under threat given that all for one is
actively sending villains after him so
by going back to the school you kind of
make the school a target and as you can
see from the rest of this chapter he's
not the only one who thinks that because
a lot of civilians are gathered outside
the gate or gathered near the gate
saying that deku can't come in they say
that midori is the one shigaraki is
going after and that everyone's talking
about it and while this is happening
president mike tries to calm them down
but it's useless and they continue by
saying that the principal guaranteed
their safety deku accepts their
complaints and starts to walk away but
ochako holds his hand and stops him she
says everything will be all right and
her narration begins she says that
bakago ide and everyone made this
possible and now they won't let him go
once again they won't let go of his hand
the chapter ends with achako questioning
who will save the heroes when they're in
pain and turning around
the thing that she says at the end there
who will save the heroes when they're in
pain this isn't the first time she said
this she said this a while ago uh i
think it was when deku left the letters
at their doors that was when she kind of
thought who's going to save him you know
he's out there by himself who's going to
help him and so this is the full circle
moment when you know she's brought him
back she's not she's not letting him go
again period i do find it interesting
though how deku was so willing to just
uh yeah you know after this whole fight
that he just had with his classmates
he's now just easily willing to walk
away and attract right to actively stop
him from doing so um so it shows that he
hasn't fully learned his lesson just yet
and he he is still willing to work on
his own um but uh but yeah we'll see how
things go from here i'm interested to
see how the ua barrier is going to work
because you know it's highly likely that
overwhelm will still send villains to
attack ua or if not villains then nomu
because he knows deku is going to be
there he'll most likely attack it
because deku is who he wants um but
we'll see how things go there's
definitely a lot of potential for this
story right now like it's in a good
place so i'm interested to see where
hiko she takes it from here just a
reminder there is no new chapter next
week there is a break um so in two weeks
time that's when we'll get the next
chapter thanks for watching as always
and until the next one peace out